how will she improve if we always accept
her delusion so let's say she said today
I want to be a better person how can she
do that if everyone is saying blame the
evil awful men seriously how how can we
improve if we can't even say this is
wrong I don't believe her women have a
tendency to just blow everything out of
proportion we're very controlling we're
very manipulative how how do we improve
if we're always fueling the delusion in
an excerpt from Kiki's book I don't
belong to you Unearthed by blogger Armen
Wiggins the actress details a volatile
and physically abusive relationship that
she was in prior to Darius Jackson
sometimes I went off on him just to get
a rise out of him and just like that our
relationship became physically and
emotionally abusive mostly on my part
and you guys just wanted me to believe
it when the pictures came out of him
like choking her or whatever